hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
Twitter today is how hundreds of
millions of people communicate
it's how the news today breaks
eighty-three percent of world leaders
are on Twitter in a way it's actually
the most instant communication network
on the planet it's augmented the
internet and how information is
disseminated but the story of how
Twitter started is one filled with
betrayal and controversy here's a
Twitter account owned by a man named
Noah gloves his bio reads I started this
if I was to tell you that Noah the owner
of this Twitter account with only 38
thousand followers helped start Twitter
but was kicked out of the company before
it got off the ground you may not
believe me but that is true so why
doesn't anyone know about Noah and why
did he get kicked out well it's partly
because of this man Evan Williams but
also because of this man Jack Dorsey it
was a coup within the company to rid
Noah not only this but co-founder of
Twitter Evan Williams may have cheated
investors out of hundreds of millions by
bluffing so let's explore how one of the
most recognizable social media companies
has such a controversial beginning most
people think that the story of Twitter
starts with Jack Dorsey or Evan Williams
but its story actually begins with Noah
and that's where we'll start you are
watching ColdFusion TV
our story starts in San Francisco in the
early 2000s Noah glass had created a
product where a user would dial a number
and the service would turn your voice
message into an mp3 message which would
be hosted on the Internet
remember these are the early days of the
web where everything was relatively new
and people were throwing around crazy
business ideas Noah would turn this
online voice mail idea into a company
called OTO one of the early investors in
OTO was a former Google employee friend
and also neighbor of Noah Evan Williams
Evan had recently sold his company
called blogger to Google and he had a
ton of cash
the idea turned from hosting voice
messages as mp3s to a podcasting
platform the company moved into an
office and started hiring more employees
one of these employees was a quiet
on-again off-again web designer and
university dropout by the name of Jack
Dorsey the 29 year old was shy after
battling a speech impediment as a child
he was living in a tiny San Francisco
apartment and had recently been turned
down for a job at a shoe store around
this time before smart phones iPods were
the hottest thing and everyone had one
in 2005 Apple announced that iTunes
would include a podcasting platform
built into every one of those tens of
millions of iPods in people's pockets
the employees of odio began to realize
that Apple had just crushed them without
warning in addition to this they just
didn't listen to podcasts as much as
they thought they would Evan Williams
who by now was the odio CEO knew that oh
do as a podcasting platform was doomed
he contemplated shutting down the
company but Noah thought that it was
best to see what the employees could
come up with
Evan agreed and in a last-ditch effort
he told the company's employees to start
coming up with ideas for a new direction
for odio employees would break into
groups and spend the whole day working
on projects
after a hard day's work the office crew
would often see live music shows and
drink late into the night usually
talking about technology during this
time Jack Dorsey and Noah glass really
hit it off and soon they were
inseparable back at work when looking at
what the staff was working on to save OD
oh no a glass gravitated towards Jack he
thought of him as one of the best stars
in the company Jack had an idea for a
completely different product that
revolved around status statuses or a
popular idea in the 2000s Facebook
featured them heavily and Foursquare was
based totally around that not to mention
the Bourbon app which would later become
Instagram he is no explaining it further
quote I got the impression jack was
unhappy with what he was working on a
lot of cleanup work on audio he started
talking to me about this idea of status
and how he was really interested in
statuses I was trying to figure out what
he found so compelling about it Noah
goes on to describe a moment when he and
Jack were talking in his car after a
night of drinking it was about 2:00 a.m.
and raining outside Jack said that he
wanted to quit the tech world altogether
and become a fashion designer Noah was
taken aback and he pushed Jack to
explain his status idea further quote
there was a moment when I was sitting
with Jack and I said oh I do see how
this could really come together to make
something really compelling it all fit
together for me one day in February of
2006 Noah and Jack presented the idea to
the rest of the company it was a system
where you could send a text to the
number four zero four zero four and the
text message would be broadcasted to all
your friends they would receive an SMS
of what you wrote and you could add more
friends via text message so what would
they call this thing after dismissing
the word twitch for a name they would
call it Twitter Noah would take charge
of the Twitter project while Jack did
the coding the original Twitter was a
social network anchored around text
messaging it sounds weird today but back
then the technology that was widely
adopted wasn't capable in
to have instant social media with you
this kind of service was the closest
thing interestingly they weren't the
only ones a service called dodgeball was
another SMS social media network with
Twitter though instead of just text
messages users could post Envy messages
via the Twitter website after the
February to the company Evan Williams
were skeptical about Twitter's potential
but regardless he put Noah in charge of
the project twitter is a social texting
service based in the contents of your
mind it works with your cell phone and
shortcode for Oh 404 and it then goes to
H in every one of your many many
actionable friends Noah was passionate
about Jack's idea and understood it by
March of 2006
odyo had a working twitter prototype in
July TechCrunch covered Twitter for the
first time their conclusion was as
follows quote if this was a new startup
I'd give it a thumbs up for innovation
and good execution of a simple but viral
idea but the fact that this comes from
odio makes me wonder what is this
company doing to make their core
offering compelling how do their
shareholders feel about side projects
like Twitter when their primary product
line is besides the excellent design a
total snoozer the tech community
couldn't see why oh do a podcasting
platform would dabble in something so
weird
regardless later that year oh do
employees became so obsessed with
Twitter that they racked up monthly SMS
bills totaling hundreds of dollars it
seemed like Twitter was an interesting
and fun toy for the employees but
nothing more
it would take an earthquake to change
all of that
in August a small earthquake shook San
Francisco and word quickly spread
through Twitter suddenly the whole
company realized what the usefulness of
the platform was News Twitter was a
fresh form of instant years both on a
macro and personal level it was an
information network not a social network
by fall of that year to to have
thousands of users back at odio
the company was splitting into two those
who worked on Twitter and those who
worked on the legacy audio stuff Evan
Williams early investor in Noah's idea
and now CEO of o dó was an interesting
character he stated that quote all
successful business people make enemies
along the way according to Business
Insider former audio investors and
employees use the word calculating to
describe him there are allegations that
Evan Williams failed to properly
compensate bloggers employees when he
sold the company to Google in 2003 his
blogger co-founder Meg hariom said quote
I don't think he took care of the people
who got him to where he was
later in 2006 at a board meeting for
Odie oh no a glass presented Twitter -
Oh Dios directors they couldn't care
less they didn't see what the point of
it was then one day in September 2006
Evan wrote a letter to ODS investors in
it he told them that the company was
going nowhere and he felt bad about it
Evan convinced the investors that they
should cut their losses and sell all
their stock back to him they agreed and
he bought back Oda but this included
Twitter
five years later assets of the company
that the original Odia investors sold
for approximately five million were now
worth at least 1,000 times more five
billion the question is did Evan ever
know that Twitter was going to be a hit
his email hints at this in the letter to
audios investors Williams wrote about
Twitter quote by the way Twitter which
he may have read about is one of the
pieces of value I see in ODI but it's
too early to tell what's there almost
two months after launch twitter has less
than 5,000 registered users I will
continue to invest in Twitter but it's
hard to say it justifies the venture
investment Oda certainly holds
especially since that investment was for
a different market altogether on the one
hand he may have just thought that
Twitter was a waste of time and he felt
bad about that but on the other hand did
Evan Connelly investors surely when the
OTO employees racked up hundreds of
dollars in SMS bills he must have seen
the potential Business Insider spoke to
a few of these investors some are okay
with it
some are jaded others think that they
were conned had Evan tricked them into
thinking Twitter wasn't worth much when
he knew that he was sitting on a
goldmine
it's impossible to know what he was
thinking but one former employee who
wished to remain anonymous said this
quote Williams decided there was
something interesting enough in Twitter
that he wanted to buy all the assets and
by everyone out what chance basically is
I bought the assets of the company from
the investors and
basically we wanted to pursue a
different path that then we were on with
oh do the two personalities of Noah
glass and Evan Williams started to clash
Noah he had now designed some of the
core features of Twitter wanted to stay
at the helm very early on Noah wanted to
split twitter off into a separate
company from odio and become the CEO in
fact he had already done the paperwork
the thing was if Evan Williams wanted to
take control of Twitter he could do so
at any time Noah was nervous about Evan
and confessed his fears to jack-jack
sympathized and said that things would
be okay
one day Evan asked Noah to go with him
for a walk and was here that Noah's
worst fears were realized Evan told Noah
that he was fired all was not as it
seems though Jack Dorsey who no abundant
with and thought of as a friend was
actually the person who wanted Noah out
Jack had recently met with Evan Williams
and threatened to quit if Noah wasn't
let go the reasons for why exactly has
never been revealed unaware of what Jack
had done behind his back Noah and Jack
would meet at a bar later that night a
defeated Noah would drink late into the
night at one point Noah told Jack that
he'd been fired Jack acted dumbfounded
and blamed Evan as the night came to a
close Noah hugged his friend and walked
home
Jack soon became CEO of Twitter and Evan
went to the chairman position
[Music]
according to many employee and investor
accounts Twitter would not have been
created without no alas everyone was
shocked at the decision Noah expresses
how he felt quote I feel betrayed by my
friends by my company by the people
around me I trusted and I worked hard to
create something with I was a little
shell-shocked so I spent a lot of time
by myself and working on things alone
in any case Evan Williams remained at
the helm of one of the premier online
companies and Noah glasses name was
largely erased from the history books it
still wasn't obvious to everyone that
Twitter would be a huge hit until the
next year in 2007 Twitter completely
dominated the South by Southwest
Interactive Conference in Austin Texas
Twitter employs strategically placed to
60-inch Plasma screens in the conference
hallways exclusively streaming Twitter
messages attendees used Twitter to find
out what was happening at the conference
panelists and speakers would often
mention the service which put it into
the public eye during the event Twitter
usage increased from 20,000 tweets per
day to 60,000 Twitter staff received the
festival's web Award prize all the while
Noah glass sat in the audience filming
was never on stage from here Twitter
began to pick up steam and became the
platform to instantly know what was
happening on the 15th of January 2009 a
US Airways flight crashed on New York
City's Hudson River a photo posted on
Twitter broke the news before the
traditional media highlighting Twitter's
role in breaking news
in November of 2013 Twitter went public
with shares being valued at $26 as the
market opened and $44 when it closed in
October of 2012 Twitter bought vien
which they released as a standalone app
in January of 2013 it was hugely popular
but eventually closed down in 2016
leaving the door wide open to tick-tock
the next year in 2017 Twitter would
finally make a profit Twitter currently
has three thousand nine hundred
employees and made 3.4 billion dollars
in revenue in 2019 a total of 1.3
billion accounts have been created with
330 million monthly active users and 145
million daily users 22% of Americans are
on Twitter and of those 10% of users
write 80% of the tweets interestingly
almost nobody uses Twitter in Australia
where I live it just doesn't make a lot
of sense to people here they view it as
a social media platform 83% of the
world's leaders are on Twitter and
journalists make up 24.6% of verified
accounts Barack Obama has the most
followers with over 111 million followed
by Katy Perry and Justin Bieber there
are 6,000 tweets every second and a
day's worth of tweets would fill a 10
million page book Twitter is becoming
useful for brands the last two years
have seen a 250 percent increase in
consumer service conversations on
Twitter on the 7th of April 2020 dosa
donated 1 billion dollars to fund covert
efforts that's 28 percent of his net
worth it's a very noble move and it does
show that jack has some good character
but I just can't help but wonder what
Jack thinks of Noah's position today
what's your version of the creation you
know there's there's so many yeah I mean
there's so many different stories that
it's not really the most important thing
anyway so would you say now I founded
Twitter or we found
Twitter it's it's always been weak it's
always been with was that frustrating to
you though to hear other people have
different versions of the Twitter
creation it's I mean it's not it's not
surprising if we focus too much on that
we're not going to move forward the past
is the past the past is the past stories
will be written the situation with noah
glass is undoubtedly sad he got kicked
out of the company that he helped build
and betrayed by someone who he thought
was his friend
noah has slipped into obscurity and is
almost nowhere to be found on the
internet these days usually there's a
lesson to be learnt at the end of these
episodes but with Jack Dorsey and Evan
Williams teaming up against him
there was almost nothing that Noah could
do though I hope that this video does
bring some recognition for his role in
the foundation of Twitter who invented
Twitter well it certainly wasn't just
Jack Dorsey alone
the real Genesis I think came from Noah
glass and Jack Dorsey and it was one
night in the car they were drunk and
they've been out drinking and dancing
which was a typical affair you know when
you're in your late 20s out in San
Francisco and Noah glass was going
through a really terrible divorce and he
and his company was failing and he was
talking to Jack and Jack had this idea
of the status update away you could
update your status and your friends
would be able to see what you were doing
but it was very simple it was very
simplistic and and Noah had this
realization being how lonely he was with
his divorce and everything that if you
could use it to connect to people and
feel quote/unquote less alone that you
would actually be able to use the
service in a completely different way
they accidentally built Twitter and as a
result completely tore their friendships
apart and some of them ended up as
billionaires as we saw today and some of
them ended up with actually next to
nothing
so thanks for watching this video if you
do want to follow me on Twitter I'll
leave it up on the screen if you want to
see the stories of a few different
social media networks I've done one on
Instagram another one on myspace which
was very interesting and one more and
how Facebook has changed Society alright
so my name is to go to-- and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll see you
again soon for the next episode in the
next episode we're going to check out
the hidden links between Google and the
CIA cheers guys have a good one cold
fusion is are you thinking
[Music]